hi I'm Logan Shawn Lloyd Rock North
Carolina western part of the state the
Appalachian Mountains we're many fun
things to do in Blowing Rock like good
shopping the shops that are downtown
like killers ice cream store very
delicious you could go to tweetsie
Railroad and a western-themed how
there's an old historic railroad
trainers you could go ski or snowboard
at one of the fancy ski resorts we have
any area or you could take a tour of the
blue ridge parkway see grandfather
mountain in the swiggy bridge on top of
it blowing rock is named that's after
the blowing rock one of the country's
oldest tourist attractions this was
caused because when a Chickasaw brave
jumped off because because he was torn
as we beat away from his lover the
updraft blue and back up to his lover's
arms it is said that even today you can
throw things off the boy and rock and
okla right back up to you if I could go
anywhere in the world I'd go to Munich
Germany I loved experienced oktoberfest
there eat german food see the expense a
glockenspiel clocks that see figurines
act scenes out every time the clock
strikes another hour or learn a little
German or go to North Weinstein castle
with its fairy tale-like essence
a National Geographic do you know what
country they give women the right to
vote until nineteen seventy one
you